In Milton's Paradise Lost Satan as an
intellectual figure and you see that
motif emerge very frequently by the way
in popular culture.
So for example,
in the lion king,
the figure of scar who's a titanic
figure is also hyper intellectual and
that's very common that the evil
scientist Motif for the or the evil
advisor to the king,
the same motif.
It encapsulate something about
rationality and what it seems to
encapsulate as the idea that rationality
like Satan is the highest angel in God's
heavenly kingdom.
It's a psychological idea.
You know that the most powerful sub
element of the human psyche is the
intellect and and it's the thing that
shines out above all within the domain
of humanity and maybe across the the
domain of life itself.
The human intellect.
There's something absolutely remarkable
about it,
but it has a flaw and the floor is that
it tends to fall in love with its own
productions and to assume that their
total solzhenitsyn,
when he was writing the Gulag
archipelago had a warning about that
with regards to totalitarian ideology.
And he said that the price of selling
your God given sole to the entrapments
of of human dogma was slavery and death
essentially.
And Satan in May in Milton's paradise
lost.
Satan decides that he can do without the
transcendent,
he can do without God.
And that's why foment rebellion.
It's something like that.
And the consequence of that,
the immediate consequence from Milton's
perspective was that as soon as Satan
decided that what he knew was sufficient
and that he could do without the
transcendent,
which you might think about as the
domain outside of what you know,
something like that.
Immediately he was inhale.
And when I read paradise lost,
I was studying totalitarianism and I
thought,
you know,
the poet,
the true poet,
like a prophet is someone who has
intimations of the future.
And maybe that's because the poetic
mind,
the philosophical or prophetic mind is a
pattern detector.
And,
and,
and there are people who can detect the
underlying.
It's like the melody of,
of a nation.
Melody has in song the song of the
nation and can see how it's going to
develop across the centuries.
You see this,
you see that nature because nature,
for example,
in the mid,
around 18,
60 or so,
and he prophesied what was going to
happen in the 20th century.
He said that he said specifically that
the specter of communism would kill
millions of people in the 20th century.
It's amazing prophecy.
He said that in the notes that became
willpower and Dostoevsky was of the same
sort of mind.
Someone who was in touch enough with the
fundamental patterns of,
of,
of human movement that they could
extrapolate out into the future and see
what was coming.
And I mean,
some people are very good at detecting
patterns,
you know,
and,
uh,
Milton I think was of that.